show off that ring oh yeah yeah I nicely
was it everything you want everything I
wanted I didn't want traditional and he
knew that and then he went above and
beyond overboard legging typical swag
forever I went to juice or every single
day for like 20 days to pick it out and
there we go well you guys I was gonna
ask how are you seem pretty happy how is
life after the show amazing I couldn't
act for like anything better like
everything I envisioned while she was in
a jury house exactly was going on right
now so I'm like princess fairy tale all
that he does everything that I want him
to do so it's beautiful yeah well I mean
it's a crazy thing you guys have been
through what's kind of been the biggest
adjustment getting back to normal life
what's it been like for you for me it's
just seeing her every day honestly
because it's like I went 2 to 3 months
without seeing her but thinking about
her and now it's like I see her every
day we're moving into a new house next
week so it's like literally a just until
real life day by day so I'm not gonna
lie that house is traumatic like coming
out into reality where and all of a
sudden everybody knows your business
people come in the supermarket and ask
me like are you in so I get good warez
yeah I'm a keep in the next aisle like
calm down
people like it's very serious and the
condiment I don't know series I just
sent them on a run like yeah so it's
serious are you helping her with that
PTSD I'm trying to like it's hard but
I'm trying to as well because I don't
have PTSD but I mean you guys are one of
those reality relationships where you
know you're so happy together we love
seeing that what have you kind of
learned about each other though because
again ups and downs the story is crazy
and amazing what have you learned about
each other in these past couple months
just um like how to communicate with
each other what makes each other tick
how to make like be happy with each
other so that's like this is learning
process every single day and we're
getting married so it's like it's not an
easy process
so like the littlest stuff can make us
take or make us happy so she's learning
more about her okay so I hate when I say
this but he's a lot more sensitive than
I ever thought it would be and since you
know how he hikes himself up like
constantly is like so I guess he was all
this stuff he likes when I do that and
I'm not kind of quiet so he's like babe
tied me up you gotta be my number one
and so like words of affirmation it's
like a big thing
yeah those lovely we'd love it love
language yeah it sounds like you guys I
mean where are we at in terms of the
track to wedding it sounds like you're
planning things learning each other
where we are we putting in some work we
want tentatively we're in September so
we know that like then now we're like
okay guestlist where we're gonna do it
who's comin like Kate colors like it's a
mess like I'm already overwhelmed but
I'm excited because it's gonna be like a
big thing it's gonna be dramatic it has
to be dramatic huge I mean tell me a
couple must for the wedding you're
thinking September big what else like
dress DJ what do you think oh my first
of all okay and this is the thing I've
been you know Miss USA modeling you know
since I was little so bridal dresses
it's gonna be a nightmare for me because
I've worn every one so I want it to be
the bomb calm I'm trying to be the most
beautiful bride it needs to be dramatic
DJ music on point everybody's coming
yeah just in the TV crew everybody comes
to the wedding that's all open invite
this wedding we're hoping we'll be
televised guys are smart you're smart
[Laughter]
well speaking of I mean what about the
Big Brother family at the wedding in the
wedding where we out of the family or
like the whole like I mean anybody from
the show I am yeah of course like a lot
of people from Big Brother will be in
our wedding just depends on who but yeah
wedding not in our way yeah our wedding
at versus that's definitely but like
it's like over the seasons like the
people that we looked up like a Rachel
Riley the Justin Cody is like everybody
they're all like reaching out and we're
like do you know why are you talking to
us like do you know who you are so yeah
they're coming okay well I mean how are
things with everybody how much are you
keeping in touch and hear you talking to
the most high of like rock stars
Betty Hailey and Scotty Sam like we talk
to them every single day make sure
they're good and everything but there's
no bad blood with anyone but literally
it's like it was split down the middle
from day one it still
like family guys we are just so happy
for you I guess we're gonna tune in to
watch your wedding by the way more
reality TV other than the wedding for
you in the future I don't know I mean
Big Brother the Amazing Race I'll do
those I think gonna fight only two
reality show this one will do it yeah
like last question you guys I guess just
how what what about each of you makes
you know like we're I'm so in love I'm
so happy like I said all the time like
she's my motivation it's like I usually
listen to like motivational speakers to
like okay I want to stay focus on my
future my career but I don't need that
like I look at her inside boom okay
for me it's like you know I went through
the most traumatic experience in the
house and to me it's like first of all
obviously like losing baby a baby was
traumatic but the fact that I told him
that I was having a baby and he didn't
run from me he was immediately
alright I'm full support what do you
need are you okay like freaking out you
know and like the producer was like all
he does is call and ask about you and I
was like he's the one he loves me so
yeah he's just been my rock so it's
pretty power I can't live without that
that rocking this one Oh
[Music]